welcome back to the big Saturday show
well it's almost here the end of former
president Trump's title 42 the pandemic
era policy allowed the U.S government to
quickly expel migrants who crossed into
the U.S illegally after Thursday it's
going to be a free-for-all the bite
Administration is in staunch denial of
that here's Homeland Security secretary
Alejandro mayorkas
our border is secure border is secure
because we are maximizing our resources
to deliver the most effective results to
our border with the most extraordinary
Workforce in the world
yeah Charlie it hasn't really seemed
secure as Millions have flooded over
here illegally without punishment and
now it's only going to get worse when
title 42 expires yeah it's going to
explode um he's such a liar it's so
amazing to look at those clips I
remember two years ago when he started
making claims like that and thinking I
made bets with people that oh he's going
to be the Fall Guy for the
administration at some point this is
going to be so bad for them because one
of the things we learned in 2016. this
is the issue of illegal immigration and
an open border has been sort of a slow
burning uh sleeper issue for 30 years
and then it just kind of all came to a
head because one guy comes along Donald
Trump and says hey this is a problem you
know and and of course it was something
Democrats and Republicans both cared
about and um and and now it's even worse
than it was over the past several
decades so I think that this is this is
going to I think that everybody in
Washington is overlooking and especially
the the Biden Administration how bad
this is going to wind up being for them
politically the question is to for me is
whether Republicans will be smart enough
to figure out how to harness it and and
uh you know make make the the tough
promises to actually do something about
it I hope so you know I hope they call
out the bite Administration and I hope
voters care about it uh you know Julie
so the vine Administration is now going
to send active duty troops but let's
take a listen to something Kamala Harris
has said in the past about deploying
troops to the Border let's take a listen
I believe that it is
inappropriate to require the limited
resources of the United States military
to be used in such a way all because
there needed to be some demonstration
for the TV cameras based on a political
agenda so that's from 2018. yeah that's
that's sweet when title 42 ends let's
just be clear there will be a full
invasion uh and in full swing of
invasion of illegal immigrants in this
country reminiscent of the Afghanistan
withdrawal okay that is how serious this
is and the fact that this White House
thinks that it's some sort of political
stunt is absolutely absurd majorcus
instead here's his take to the
individuals themselves who are thinking
of migrating that's you if you're
watching us in Mexico or Venezuela
listen to this warning do not believe
the Smugglers please access the official
government Publications please access
the official government information on
the Department of Homeland Security
security website for accurate
information I'm really sure that
Smugglers right now are going
www.homelandsecurity.com oh it says here
the border is not open so we should
deter what is the deterrent there is no
dot gov I'm so sorry
um you know I mean seriously there is no
deterrent whatsoever and for majorca's
to come out and say that the border is
not open as an outright lie obviously
this white house is in complete denial
and with 42 over I mean she talks about
how you know bringing troops to the
Border would be bad back in 2018 now
they're bringing troops to the Border
well maybe you shouldn't have taken them
out of Afghanistan and then you'd know
what you were doing they don't know what
they're doing overseas they don't know
what they're doing at our borders they
don't know what they're doing period
well and I want to pull up this so so
now Joe Biden he created this crisis and
now he's trying to use it in the
fentanyl crisis to re-up section 702 of
the foreign intelligence surveillance
acts there's this political head writing
as you see there at home it says Biden
has a new pitch to re-up a controversial
surveillance program and Republicans
might like it it goes on to say this
quote
keep going quote the by demonstration is
leaning into a politically potent issue
fentanyl trafficking from Mexico to
convince lawmakers to reauthorize a
controversial George W bush era
surveillance program let's take a listen
to some of the debate that's happening
on Capitol Hill over this
I lose sleep over the 3.4 million
warrantless searches of Americans
Communications using fisa section 702.
it's more important than ever that we
ensure that our civil rights are
protected as our national security
agencies gather this intelligence
Americans are being picked up in this
incidental collection we don't know the
number my guess is it's pretty darn big
so Tom not only did he create this
crisis at the border but now he's trying
to use it to re-up the ability to spy on
us the American citizens yeah it's just
it's like whatever they can use to get
their little pet projects I mean 702
that's dumb title 42 is dumb I'm not
worried about illegal immigration
because of covet and you know that
shouldn't be our stop Gap oh please
let's keep title 42. I mean that whole
thing was idiotic anyway so yeah it's
ridiculous but mallorcas can just stare
into the camera and say the border is
not open and he knows most of the press
is not going to call him on it because
in the end whenever you have these
discussions people say well we all want
the same thing we don't want the same it
and this is where Republicans run into
trouble is they don't play hardball
enough with these guys basically you've
got to confront them with the fact that
we know they want the Border open that's
part of the globalist mentality that
these people have they really don't like
borders they don't even like the idea of
nation states anymore the globalists
really want a borderless country and
eventually it's going to be too late and
they're going to say oh well uh you know
what are we going to do yeah I mean this
is happening because they want it to
happen uh well good points Tom hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else